today we're discussing one of the most
hyped topics in one piece Zoro and
sanji's devil through pow so make sure
to stay tuned for that chel parking
within and smash that like button if you
enjoy seeing one piece videos like this
one join the knocko by subscribing so
you don't miss future one piece videos
and updates smashing that subscribe
button also means helping us get closer
to that insane goal of 2 million
subscribers here on YouTube which would
be epic of you and now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
so we know Zoro is very powerful and
it's true that he doesn't necessarily
need a fruit but what if I told you that
he already has one anyways it wouldn't
be the first time Zoro having a devil
fruit was brought up even Oda himself
played around with the idea before in a
question corner he was asked if Zoro and
other straw hats including Sanji which
we'll get to were to become ability
users AKA devil fruit users what kind of
fruits do you think they would have
eaten Oda answered he would like to see
Zoro with kaido's fish fish fruit
mythical model seru but he'd prefer if
zoro's sword had the azur dragon fruit
instead of Zoro himself so ignoring the
fact that kaido has that fruit currently
if he's still alive that that is which
he probably is knowing kaido I think
it's fascinating that Oda revealed he'd
love to see zoro's sword specifically
with a mythical Zone devil fruit not
only did he acknowledge it's possible
but even that he'd like to see it Oda
obviously wouldn't reveal Zoro already
having a mythical Zone sword but dancing
around the idea in a favorable way begs
us to explore this possibility in more
detail and it makes a lot of sense once
you start looking into it and yes in my
view also it would make a lot more sense
if Zoro sword had the devel fruit rather
than him he's still the user of The
Sword and in a way the wielder of the
fruit Power by extension and to all
those people who already wrote in the
comments that he obviously doesn't have
a fruit power because he can swim well
this would allow him to swim normally
while also utilizing ad Del fruit power
outside of the water now what event
specifically made me want to explore
this idea more seriously aside from Oda
suggesting it himself well to begin with
I'm fascinated with enma and the amount
of coverage and focus it got during the
wano arc and is one of the 21 great
grade swords or 21 excellent grade
swords depending on what translation you
use use it is one of only two known
weapons to ever injure kaido before the
present day events of the story the
official of his translation says enma is
said to split the Earth to the bottom of
hell and is one of the 21 excellent
grade swords Zoro is warned that only
one man has tamed enma and that was kuki
Odin this kind of personification is
also associated with zones now because
as we found out from the five Elders in
the wano ark they specifically have
Wills of their own and so it's not
impossible that the gumu fruit for
example which is a mythical Zone was
evading the government for 800 years as
we proceed enma will similarly appear to
have a will of its own way more than
anything we've seen from other swords we
see Zoro use it in the beginning to
slice off the coastline shocking even
Sanji it's not an easy blade to wield
though since it exudes the wielder Zio
on its own it slices more than needed
and although Zoro has some trouble in
the beginning he actually does better
than most wielding it since we're told a
normal swordsman would already be a mere
husk if they used it like Zoro did Zoro
being Zoro of course accepts the
challenging sword now the interesting
thing is that enma is the name of the
king of hell in Japanese Buddhist myth
the judge of dead Souls this God is
associated with a dangerously difficult
to control personality another bit of
trivia is that its size was very
inconsistent since despite Zoro and Odin
being vastly different heights the sword
looks normal in both of their hands
putting all of this together it's clear
that this is no ordinary sword and at
this point already we might assume that
it has some sort of mythical own human
human fruit model enma or model god of
the underworld within it on a side note
the whole God or king of Hell idea
reflects Rogers and Ra's relationship
really well as rayy to was called the
dark King while Roger was the pirate
king I feel like Zoro and Luffy will
have a very similar dynamic as well and
we know that Oda loves his parallels but
let's move on because the clues and
evidence don't stop there Zoro uses enma
during the fight against kaido and big
mom he tells himself he's going to have
to unleash this enma a bit more he
eventually gets an opportunity to cut
kaido with enma during chapter 102 page
12 kaido is asked what's that while
zoro's enma is glowing big bomb says and
I quote look out that's no ordinary
sword that quote in and of itself is
another big clue that enma is special in
a possible hint that it has a Zone devil
fruit Zoro uses the move flying dragon
Blaze and he misses he does cut off The
Horn from the onigashima skull but even
if it didn't land it's still significant
it was a slash that scared to yonko and
kaido who often doesn't void attacks
decided to avoid it keep in mind kaido
didn't even try to avoid gear five
Luffy's finisher move so this is a big
deal he also says how does his Katana
bear the presence of Odin within it here
we get another parallel to how zunesha
was sensing Joy boy's presence in Luffy
and why did he sense it not because
Luffy was the same as the old Joy boy
but because they had the same devil
fruit and so it's possible kaido isn't
actually sensing Odin he's just sensing
the fruit within the sword that he's
come to associate with Odin later as
Zoro prepares another attack kaido asks
himself is that Katana the source of
that strange hockey Zoro uses black rope
Dragon twister attack and it actually
hurts kaido as killer excitedly points
out that Zoro actually cut kaido's
scales it's also noteworthy that before
he launches this attack zoro's swords
Aura took the shape of a dragon during
chapter 103 on page 10 kaido 2 says he
actually cut me that hurts I see that
must be Odin's sword Zoro Cuts
Prometheus multiple times so he has
trouble helping big mom and then during
chapter 110 Zoro tells law what he's
about to do is the limit of his ability
he tells kaido who is going to smash
Luffy's brains or heart that that's his
captain and if he wants to crush
anyone's skull he'll have to start with
Zoro so epic he uses demon AA nine sword
style Asura blades drawn Dead Man's game
yes it's a long name but it's useful to
pay attention to zoro's attacks he uses
words like demon and Asura was a class
of beings who opposed the V Gods like
the name enma Zoro plays up this
underworld demon spin for himself
through his attacks at this point kaido
and LW are shocked that Zoro succeeds in
cutting him across the chest and at that
point kaido notices that Zoro is a
conqueror's hockey user as well but like
Luffy unaware of his true fruit Zoro
just says he has no idea what kaido is
talking about before he falls to the
ground kaido Praises him saying he did
enough the wound will remain with him
like Odin's attacks did this shows how
impressively strong Zoro with enma is
enough to leave a lasting wound on a
myth mythical Zone user one dubb the
strongest creature in the world
considering this it wouldn't be a
shocker if Zoro had the help of a
mythical Zone to do it and that's not
taking anything away from Zoro because
if you think about it kaido definitely
had the help of a mythical Zone to
defend his attack and let's not forget
about how before this Zoro block
conquest of the sea a combo attack by
big mom and kaido it was a bone chilling
moment amazing he saved three Supernova
captains by blocking the two yono's
combo attack and still had the energy to
drop drop a lasting wound on kaido and
even get his praise crazy stuff and then
as if impressing everyone blocking a
Yono combo attack and permanently
wounding kaido wasn't enough Zoro is
temporarily healed later and goes on to
fight King the Yono Commander with the
highest known Bounty a whopping 1.39
billion berries hilariously enough while
he's fighting King he also has the
energy to promise to kill Sanji if he
stops being himself after the latter
unleashes his finisher on Queen later as
Zoro is thinking he needs to find find
out what race King is if he hopes to
defeat him enma starts going off
responding to hi's shamian playing the
sword causes Zoro to scream in pain as
his arm shrivels up clearly this sword
has a will of its own more so than we've
seen with any other weapon Zoro straight
up tells it like he's talking to a
misbehaving pet who gave you permission
to Unleash Your Power enma King even
comments what's wrong having an argument
Queen then tells us that King is a
lunarian a monster capable of surviving
in any natural environment and even adds
in in the distant past his people were
known as Gods so this goes perfectly
with what we were talking about zoro's
attacks position him as a demon opposing
gods and here he has to cut down in a
sense a god Zoro continues to talk to
enma telling it to wait stop again like
a person trying to tame their pet or a
wild animal when he takes advantage of
the weird situation King even says a
swordsman held back by his own sword
that's a new one again showing that this
is not normal for swords to have this
much of a personality this much of a
will King as the strongest commander of
the strongest creature in the world
would have had ample opportunity to see
something like this if it was just a
weapon thing and not a special devil
fruit thing Zoro then goes on to treat
all his swords like his friends while
King is surprised that he died just to
save his sword during his flashback Zoro
is told by the old man of the village
aka the master swordsmith that a sword
has its own personality a swordsman must
Master it and bend it to his will so
some might assume that this is what's
happening with enma but I hope I've
shown enma as a special case and in my
view it's done things that are well
beyond explaining a way by saying all
swords have a personality he tells Zoro
in the flashback that there was one
blade he crafted when he was a young man
it was the greatest weapon he ever made
its disposition was deadly serious just
holding it in your hand sent a shiver
down the spine so I gave that
Masterpiece the name of the king who
watches over hell the king of the
underworld enma and back to the present
Zoro sees the aura enma's giving off
even while he's not touching it he
doesn't see that with the other swords
like Zone devil fruits blacksmith
shimsky kosaburo says a great blade can
see into a person and chooses Only The
Swordsman who best suits it and come on
would it not be perfect for zoro's
demonon theme and for enma's underworld
theme for them both to be associated
with a devil fruit Zoro concludes that
enma came to him so it could test him
Zoro says it was his strength that was
lacking rather than the sword being
Wicked rather than trying to limit it
Zoro allows it to drain as much hockey
as it wants asking it Odin wielded you
as though you were light as a feather
enma question mark Zoro remarks if he
asked to keep exuding hockey like this
it'll kill him but then he says no
that's perfect because of so much
conqueror Hockey being released
surrounding Beast Pirates pass out and
King remarks to Zoro so you intend to be
a king like I said New Era dark King
Zoro has to be a thing Zoro uses attacks
with king of Hell in the title against
King referencing enmod the final one
which finishes King off is called King
of Hell three sword serpent 103 Mercy's
Dragon damnation afterwards Zoro says
guess I might as well become the king of
hell and then has enough energy to
create another sword slash so powerful
that it sends him flying back to the
island now all of this alone would be
enough in my opinion to Warrant a zoro's
sword has the king of Hell devil fruit
Theory but possibly the biggest proof
comes next during chapter 138 we see
something truly unique for one piece we
see Zoro who remember took medicine that
would temporarily relieve his pain from
the Yono fight so he could could fight
King but then the pain would come back
with a vengeance even worse and that's
not counting all the new damage he
accumulated from the King fight so he
must be as near to death as you can get
and that's when it happens he sees what
looks like the Grim Reaper it appears
before him as Zoro remarks what's going
on my body won't move no stop it don't
do it and this led to theories that
maybe he's hallucinating and it's Brooke
coming to help which wasn't the case or
maybe he's so weak he's just
hallucinating which wouldn't make sense
to me either Oda wouldn't throw in
something like that only to later say it
was a complete hallucination like what's
the point of that then there's a
possibility that it is the Grim Reaper
coming to collect zoro's life but that
wouldn't make sense either from what
we've seen in one piece there haven't
really been any real Gods aside from
Godly devil fruits and people so for me
the best explanation is that this is the
manifestation of enma's King of the
underworld devil fruit and one
possibility is that we finally see the
figure because it has undergone
Awakening just like we didn't know Luffy
had the sun god fruit until he underwent
Awakening this to me would explain all
the inconsistencies with why was edma so
different from other swords to what is
the Grim Reaper figure so let me know
your thoughts do you agreed that it's
possible or even likely that Oda gave
zoro's new sword a mythical Zone fruit
as he himself said he'd like to do or do
you think there's another explanation
for all of these crazy events
surrounding Zoro during the wano arc and
if so what are the explanations I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the matter
especially about the Grim Reaper unless
proven otherwise I honestly believe that
this Theory makes a lot of sense but
we'll have to wait and see to know for
sure and now we come to Sanji and his
devil fruit Powers you might have
noticed that like Zoro Sanji can swim
and so yes like with Zoro his devil
fruit powers are less straightforward
than just eating a devil fruit now in
the same SPS where Oda revealed zoro's
sword would have the fish fish fruit
model Azor Dragon he also reveals that
Sanji would have senior Pink's devil
fruit the swim swim fruit we also saw
this specific power duplicated in the
seraphim s shark I wonder if that could
have been a little clue from Oda that
I's devil fruit Powers too would be the
result of scientific modification we saw
his unbelievable superhuman Powers at
work during the wano arc first of all
it's worth mentioning the fact that even
before this Arc where his superhuman
Powers just got ridiculous his leg would
seemingly catch on fire when he attacked
people I don't have to point out that
that is not a normal trait by any means
then he uses the flame and force kick to
send Queen's giant dinosaur head
spinning like a helicopter he outlines
his awakened scientific Powers himself
exoskeleton muscle strength and mile
speed he's even able to Overlay the
exoskeleton with finally honed Armament
hockey to create tougher and hotter
Flames the Flames turn from normal color
to Blue and ultimately he lands a
finishing attack using his newly
awakened powers and blue flames to
defeat Queen and before that he took a
dinosaur wielded blade to the neck and
his neck was fine and the blade
shattered it's honestly an insane level
of durability he gained and it made his
fight against Queen seem like a cakewalk
compared to zoro's fight against King
not to mention that he's so fast now
that he can be practically invisible
when he wants to but even if we say Okay
genetic manipulation let the super
strength speed and durability that still
doesn't explain his fire powers I mean
even before the hotter blue flames
people were asking Oda how sanji's like
could withstand the heat while the same
heat would Scorch his targets order
replied that the attack Burns hot but
sanji's heart burns hotter keep that in
mind as we move forward when Queen sees
the fire produced by Sanji he says only
lunarians can create fire at will like
that but Sanji just replies it's due to
his passion now yes this has led many to
speculate that Sanji has lunarian DNA
because of his genetic manipulation
which is possible even if it works
differently for instance for lunarians
they say that they have near
invulnerability while the flame burns on
their back but not when it goes out we
saw that Sanji can tank attacks like he
has invulnerability even when no parts
of his body are on fire while the
seraphim which were made using lunarian
DNA do have the flames on the back rle
Ru not to mention Wings thus it may be
more likely that for Sanji they somehow
succeeded in imitating a fire-based
devil fruit power after all Queen was
wrong it's not only lunarians that can
create fire like that it is devil fruit
users too like Ace for one now am I
saying it had to be the flame flame
fruit no but I will say that that would
work very well with what Oda said
specifically that sanji's heart burns
hotter than his leg if he meant that
literally and not figuratively as most
people take it then all of a sudden this
Theory makes a lot of sense because we
know flame flame through users like Ace
and Sabo can set their bodies including
their hearts Ablaze # rip and Goku and
if you enjoyed learning more about
characters like Sanji and Zoro then you
won't want to miss my Oda Finally
Revealed zoro's father and his father's
devil fruit video link on screen right
now like And subscribe to help us reach
our insane goal of 2 million subscribers
here on YouTube and I'll see you in the
next one